article orally run-length encoding which
this should be very very straightforward
but I bet it won't be because nothing
ever is
so importing run-length encoding files
so we should have some run-length
encoding files here so let's take a look
here so oh dear
ok what on earth are we doing here well
where else do we ever import inactivated
stuff I mean I you don't think I don't
think I know of any other case ok so
we're going to invent a whole new thing
ok so if I say activate this come on
ok come on ok we supporting that in
cellular automaton or not right now ok
so this is not useful correct so we know
we want why don't we convert those
things to our cellular automata
specification what is our specification
for that life this is the life rule I
don't care B 3 SS 23 we have a
representation of that his head on this
call oh he was in the previous meeting
well he's supposed to be here right his
listed as being here it's ok so for
cellular automaton I don't know the
translation immediately but see these
associations wherever it is growth cases
etc etc etc that's what those represent
I would guess that well let's take a
look
I would guess somewhere here it will say
how that works now the question is
whether we can and this is coming up in
some other cases as well whether we can
return we definitely do not want to
return this okay
we want to return something we just I
mean we don't want to invent a new
mechanism for this incredibly bizarre
corner case by making sense so but but
even if the number if the rule is
something that our seller Tommy Tong
supports we still return the inactive
because we want to see you know no no we
do not we we figure out how to do this
so that we can feed the whole thing
including the initial condition to
cellular automaton so for example in
here okay so if we go down here and we
say well where is it
rule specified by associations okay so
there it is with things specified by an
association okay so I suspect what we
should do is to have it be the case that
that first argument there's as I said I
think this is going to come up in some
other cases too in fact it just came up
in a case that I was just working on
that first argument should be capable of
having an initial condition piece in the
Association and then dropped the second
argument it's slightly weird but
alternatively we could do something
where the first argument is a nested
Association or has the possibility of
being something of the form you know
cellular automaton
of rule and then initial condition and
then we drop the second argument by
making sense so that we then return that
combination from from the system right
now in terms of export we're going to
need some mechanism as well to
export so we're gonna need something
like this for that too aren't we
that makes sense is that a symbolic form
it's not only evaluating to the the full
thing evaluates but look the whole point
is without the initial condition right
and without the number of time steps so
what we could do here I mean I suppose
what we could do is we could say
something like that I mean it's a little
bit hacky but um did you get what I'm
saying to keep the structure of the
arguments but to have then the the
initial condition come from the first
argument did you understand what I'm
saying I do but I think it's for Jose
read to comment it's so we're not
developing so lord I understand that but
but that's why these discussions are
complicated right because you can't know
what you're doing in a vacuum and
returning something it doesn't even
evaluate isn't useful I mean it's it's
great that you can decode the sparse
array and so on but you know there's
more to it
is that here yes okay so we need a
decoder for these rule specifications
and to our rule specifications is this
complicated what is b3 s 23 in terms of
our rule specifications birth three
survived two and three
yeah we've we've written that several
times off to find the code again okay
could you go look for it right now
and okay so it's let's be specific here
we've said this is growth cases and what
what is the other one so we named them
growth cases right so this has to know
so so to make this work right it's got
to have a dimension to right it's got to
know that because that presumably is
specified by this aurélie format yes or
no does it say how many dimensions it's
end
the same dimensions it's in right okay
so so what you're going to need to
return I'm typing avoid typing and
everybody's here um there you know what
you're gonna need to return is whatever
and I don't know how it knows the
neighborhood does b3s 23 does not in and
of itself specify the neighborhood how
do you know that from that specification
oh I'm getting the code okay all right
fine I if you are looking to - which
rule B 3 as 20 3/4 oh no we just figured
that out from it but what we need to
know is there's there's in here you see
these these pieces right b3 must be
growth cases s 23 is growth survival
cases ok
the problem is you have to say what
neighborhood the rule operates on or
that's all meaningless you have to say
in here right we have to say so I don't
think that's the way we do it we just
say um dimension - okay so then we say
neighborhood well we don't know we need
to know that right and then we would say
in this particular case growth cases
arrow list 3 growth survival cases our
oh I've posted code in the chat if it's
long code the chat isn't bad plate no
you'll need to send it by email it won't
it won't work from there ok all right
very unlikely to work from there
nope didn't work send it by no place to
me and sent okay all right can you
answer the question how do we find out
from what is in the arleigh file what
the neighborhood is for the rule wait a
minute this isn't right this isn't what
we wanted this is not useful no ed what
we're looking for is the converter from
the string the string to this form okay
we already have this association which
probably well represents those things so
spring to numbered yes that's all we
need
well no but we need where's the complete
grammar of what can show up in an hourly
file who has that complete grammar
that's what I'm asking for don't think
that exists because you want me to go
find it you want me to go find it I can
go look at the source code and find it
right do I really need to do that
I don't think it exists because there's
much more complicated cases that Galli
handles okay
they do they do thousands of different
weird like Margolis and I understand
so do we so can we so we have to
translate those things that's the point
that's what we're signing up for when we
agree to you know do a format right
right they've got hundreds or me really
let me see some different cases okay so
where is that well it's it's they've got
special code written in Lua Pascal and
other languages to hand
all these different rule cases from okay
this sounds like [ __ ] to me okay
you're gonna I'm gonna I'll simply email
these people and try and get the
information myself this is not really
useful is exactly not what we wanted
okay okay
this isn't useful this is not gonna be
helpful the fact that we can convert the
sparse array is nice but the rest of it
is not useful
are there test files for this from golly
for example yeah yes there are the test
files I can send you the link in a
second please what is this what is
single state here what is that just but
that's that basically means that this
file contains the single state
information while multi state means that
there are more than like in this
particular case this is a file that
contains information about two states
the initial state and some arbitrary
state stored in the file okay but so
what do we get what we generate them
we're still generating a a for some
reason we're still generating a two
dimensional array in that case why are
we not generating a list of arrays for
example right for that we have this full
data so we basically decided since the
main thing is the initial state we will
be over always returning the initial
state information and if someone wants
to extract the full information we have
this element full data and that you can
basically get an ass's list of
associations that describes the whole
file hold on but but is the file is the
raw file a run length encoding of a
single two dimensional array the resist
I'm sorry this multi-state file yeah
this multi-state file is a
representation of a single two
dimensional array or is it a
representation of multiple
two-dimensional arrays this particular
one is representation of two
two new race two 2d arrays so we should
return a list I think but I okay I
understand that so what are you doing
here you're combining those two 2d
arrays somehow you know if you go to
full data safe subsection so you have
basically lists of associations
describing the whole file okay
and so basically each of them
corresponds to so what are you doing in
the first case you've got five 501
elements so you just kept the first one
here that's the right right yeah yeah
only the first state information is
returned whenever you request an element
except for full data how does that
correspond to other things we're doing
shoddy maybe we could do image an image
list currently and TIFF for instance if
you have a multi-front if we do a less
bit by default we return the lists of
images where it's multi fine yes when
it's a single frame so the default
import element changes depending on
whether we have a single frame or multi
frame we could potentially do the same
thing here there are no go ahead except
that the image may become very large
some of the there is a possible issue
section down in the notebook that says
sometimes these sparse arrays are very
long large well because they're
originally represented in hashed form on
weirdy hashing them is that correct
correct okay that's not going to work
either there's nothing nothing is useful
by D hashing them because we're just not
going to be able to do anything with
them yep so and then it seemed like from
the discussion from at most of the time
people care about the initial condition
anyways it's rare that people store
alternative states in the early file so
the default being image seemed to be a
fine default we could add an image list
which is an explicit image list well
that's fine but I'm not sure the image I
mean does cellular automaton work with
image
the cellular Thomasson work with image
they certainly could I don't know
whether it does I I think that was the
thing that I said should happen a while
ago I'm not sure it did happen
let's take a look that's I think one of
the suggestions on there they're things
to the disgust salerto mcconnell rule
comma image no okay
well i think that should work if that
works i mean look this thing obviously
has to be integrated with what's our
automaton does so it's not really very
useful okay so if the default and i
don't think it's very useful to return
something if orally is primarily used
for cellular automata i don't know
whether that's the case is it the case
it seems to me yes okay well in that
case we should return the thing that you
stick into cellular automaton as the
default thing i think i mean you're
probably probably probably probably let
me think about that for a second the
default element well if someone accepted
an image I guess we could return images
of the fourth element I mean that as
soon as you know what rule it's dealing
with and perhaps we can assume that if
you're doing this it's like units or
something that there's a you know a
reasonable the false assumption that you
know that okay let's take a look at the
test files here okay that's interesting
what are those guys put on there
oh this is something completely
different but where am I looking in this
in this folder so this is
this is called life wiki folder so the
link didn't work that I sent in the chat
let's try it again but I don't think so
no this is try this the other one I sent
cement see no this didn't it ignored the
links it just gave the top level if the
link from Charlie doesn't work I also
shared the whole folder with you so you
should be seeing it on your main page of
all cloud this worked ok ok so let's
open a a the typical so what what um
what is this going to open in who knows
oh great okay well let's just um what
can we open this with how can we I mean
I guess we can just import this from
this is kind of a yucky thing to do we
could try saying file names here
of that if this is gonna work um this
have any chance of working
nope I doubt it so is there a file : URL
here well okay so this for example I'll
pick some random thing here if I say
copy that as a string right I should get
the header information okay so now where
is the okay that's the place thing it's
33 y equals 8 rule equals whatever
that's the thing I'm dealing with there
right that's the rule specification ok
these are common
these are structured comments but where
are we preserving the structure of those
cars
yes we are okay all right let's pick
another random example here so this is
the complete thing or other sub
directories this is the test files yeah
okay
so how about some non-game of life test
files do you think they have them I'm
sure they do I don't know their names to
tell immediately now it's just more of
the same
okay so okay so let's look then again I
mean you know I'm a little disappointed
that the Magali people didn't I mean
they were they were working on some
connector to often language a few years
ago and for some reason that never got
finished and I guess we didn't
communicate with them um but we
obviously need to see what their grammar
is and they must have some central place
in their source that shows their grammar
right and we should go find that so we
understand what we're dealing with but
it does seem to be the case that such a
large majority of these a game of life
things that's probably enough by default
to give the image so long as we can
evolve the image until Jonathan if you
scroll down Stephen actually you know
what that's not gonna work because
there's plenty of things which are
hashed which have this hashed format
which we don't deal with right now so
it's going to be crazy if we have
something right so the hash thing
it's essentially a quadtree format of
some kind how does it relate to what we
do with for example image pyramids and
so on
anybody know sorry I don't see your
connection there okay so the hashing
thing actually amusingly enough bill
Gosper somebody who we hear from
practically every day with all kinds of
cool things he does but originally
announced that whole thing at a
conference I organized in 1983 but you
know the idea is right you understand
the idea and right now you are decoding
that hashing correct yes okay but so the
what the question is if we were going to
preserve the hashing in our system and
actually run with it in cellular
automaton what would we do June 7 I'm
asking yep
so what do we think the answer is if we
wanted to have an image for example or a
sparse array that did that kind of
hashing right that has a sub element
that I mean effectively it's like some
kind of patched version of sparse array
as in sparse array is giving you an
individual element and it says here it
is when it feels like giving it to you
but the hashing thing would be giving
you a sub array that it says to place in
a particular place when it feels like it
so to speak that makes sense but it does
so hierarchically one thing we might
want to implement is galleys is a
Gospels weird scheme which is better
than sparse arrays we might want to
implement that but that's what I was
just talking about it that's what I was
just talking about I asked the question
in Gospels hashing scheme what is the
representation that we would use in our
language of a array represented with
that hashing scheme did you understand
the question right yeah I don't think we
have it yet no we don't have it that's
why I'm always
would it be if we had it pyramids are
just really scaled what you're
explaining seem to be some azimuth
hierarchical partitioning what it is is
that you can say in this scheme you can
say this region right I mean it's it's
basically saying there's a lot of
repeated regions there's all the things
that get repeated and potentially you
can do that hierarchically but even one
level would probably be very useful so
there might be a I don't know some you
know giant glider structure II thingy
that is a you know 500 by 500 thing and
what one saying is that thing that sub
array is placed in this position right
so you have essentially a list of sub
arrays eventually you're going to place
everything but you know you can do this
hierarchically but you're basically
saying to form the final array you do it
by placing hierarchically a sequence of
sub arrays at these rods and positions
in this thing right yeah so what is our
mechanism for you know if you want to
place the sub array in a sparse array
how do you do it
so I'm saying okay so we can do that
thing because sparse array precisely
refuses to get elements being a race I
agree but it would be nice to have that
sort of extension like they're
constructing a matrix by blocks yeah
right
and potentially hierarchically so so I
mean this would probably be something
like hierarchical sparse array and it
would be something like um but I don't
know how you would name the pieces you
would probably have something where
yeah I don't know you know in in in hash
life you're using hashes I think to name
them but I'm not I'm not sure that that
doesn't really make a difference that
that's the way it works but you know it
will be some series of things that
builds up to the full array need an
extra are a hierarchical I misspelled it
horribly yeah okay um the yeah we don't
want it to be implemented without the
are um okay so look okay first of all to
avoid what we getting here you should
call this rule string or something and
comments I'd understand these comments
so you have different kinds of if I were
to import that file wherever it was the
file that I was just looking at here so
if I did an import of this one
well actually should just work in this
version right it should just yeah just
do its thing so if I say that comma old
data oops
are you in the same yes I am I don't
know why that didn't work that's the
thing to check that maybe doesn't pick
up the mime type of the HTTP request
which it should I mean and it may be not
the mime type at least the file
extension there I don't know how to do
that exactly okay so I specifically
asked you do you preserve or those are
all comments there no no they're not
oh I see name and what's OH
I think this is still a comment well
it's not it's obviously got a hash n and
the hash o which have been lost here
there's obviously some structure to this
which is then lost here okay so we
should find out what that actually means
is that documentation for golly okay
you know what I think we should do I
think we should get you guys in contact
with um one of the people who works on
golly who was interested in doing this
hook up several years ago it sounds like
you guys have done the heavy lifting
part of that it's time for them to give
us a bunch of information about how to
do this in more detail um I think that's
where we have to go with this because I
you know obviously you don't want to
just squash out metadata here am I
making sense you know I mean I don't
know what the you know probably hash
means a generic comment but obviously
those letters mean something right but I
still think it's useful let's see
whether we can figure out what to put in
in this version that doesn't you know
doesn't deal with all these things our
typical convention of saying full data
[Music]
do we want to call this thing I guess we
call this data um yeah important as an
image may fail so important as data
still somehow works oh because it still
remains sparse right at least that level
of sparsity even if it doesn't hash lis
sparse it's at least buzz but there'll
be ones that fail because they only can
be imported as hash lis sparse things
she understand what I'm saying
hierarchically sparse things so
I think what we should do I think for
now although it's not going to work that
well but for now we should make the
default element be data we should have a
full data element the default data
element should well how do we deal with
the multi case the multi multi array
case data is still representation of the
first state on me I understand that I
understand it so what's the
representation of the list of states we
only have full lady before I understand
so sorry
in other cases what do we do have image
an image list okay I don't think we've
ever introduced data list or well then
maybe we shouldn't call this may be the
default element okay why don't we call
this array and say array and array list
and have the default element be array is
that reasonable is that crazy
based on our other conventions that's
fine I think array and array this is
fine okay
so then for this version will have array
ArrayList and now if I were to take one
of these sparse arrays here and I was
just going to say image of that will it
work all that come out inverted it comes
out inverted well it's inverted in a
sense that's something we would have to
deal with in the cellular automaton
function right is in other words what's
black what's white did you get what I'm
saying I mean that the image data of
that is the sparse array so in your case
if I would say here comma image
yeah I don't think that's the right
thing to do because people who are
looking at these images right they don't
want to see the inverted image and that
means so in is there a way of putting
hump you understand the issue right so
when you got this out here how did you
get that image how did you get that oh
you got that with an array plot yes but
as an image Wow
which way round should we do it you want
my graphics element
what do you maybe want a graphics
element no that's not useful because
you've got to be able to feed it to
solar otamatone yeah well I'm thinking
this image isn't very useful that we
shouldn't support that because just
gonna confuse people and that it doesn't
help any way because it's gonna unpack
it and you know to go from the sparse
array to the image is easy anyway am I
making sense yes so okay so I think what
we should support is array ArrayList
those are the defaults and full data
which I guess just looks like this and
has either an array or an ArrayList in
it it's always gonna have array but it's
then gonna be a list of those
associations that have a raised in it oh
I see okay okay fine fine but by default
by default do you want for multi-state
or Alize we return an ArrayList actually
just the array and what do you mean a
multi-state what do you mean by that
you oh you mean when yeah no I said by
default we should return the ArrayList
in the case where there is an ArrayList
we should buy what we should do is have
the default switch between array and
ArrayList yep that's similar to other
file photo image file formats yep
right
it's fine you you can have a thing
called comments I guess or should we
call it metadata or we can go to call it
comments
that's fine use that for now but we're
definitely gonna look at that structure
I agree yeah no I understand so just
just pick out comments for now and then
I don't think we should bother with this
rule thing cuz I think that's a big
muddle and we don't know what format to
return it in okay so I think for now
let's not do that that's that's correct
let's not do that right now okay so what
is this ie a a a 1 earth is hot and 32
just a random picked really no nothing
and don't do it echoing background then
don't do something random I mean in
other words what we should do here in
the case where okay if it's a binary
image let's say it's a ternary image
okay
presumably there's a way of importing an
arleigh file without a rule
specification we should look at that but
that's what I would do don't make up a
rule okay in fact I wouldn't make up a
rule well should you by default if it's
a binary image to fall to the b3 s23
rule that's a little unclear to me I
mean in other words the export if you
were to give the Association you know
you should be able to export as you're
doing presumably here presumably you can
export the full Association correct
right you can um you know what I would
just put a file
I would just do it with um export to
orally with the Association you can put
the rule in and so on I think if you
don't do that you should just not
include a rule okay you should just have
the the data if you're exporting a pure
sparse array just you know export that
now is there any specification in the AR
le format that says the depth of the
array none that I'm aware of
okay well then I really see what it does
but I would just just a naked thing
without well I see they've given this so
we need to find out probably from them
what we should do if we basically don't
think we know the rule to get what I'm
saying because the thing we can put fill
in but if here we just fill in something
blank presumably you can change that
there file format to see what to do but
that's what I would do there on the
export okay and I wouldn't have to check
but I think both Kali and us are going
to fail for files like that without
knowing the exact rule for they make any
difference it's just it's just I mean
it's the issue that you don't know the
depth what is the issue does this format
have in it the does that encode the the
bit-depth or not no but the thing I'm
trying to say is that the decoding
depends on the rule
no it doesn't it only depends on the bit
depth it depends on the bit depth from
the dimension writer ternary rule will
probably have different coding from a
binary rule and a rule in two dimensions
has different coding from the rule in
one dimension probably with other than
that it shouldn't be any difference
right right
and rule defines whether it's single
state encoding or mod
I don't know I mean I don't really see
how it does it in this particular rule
here maybe ed knows with most cases for
ternary and higher they go to MCL format
instead well do we support that okay so
then let's just assume I mean okay if it
isn't binary why don't we just fail if
this format doesn't even deal with
higher than binary I mean I understand
you've got a byte related one here right
yeah okay how did that work how does
that work how there is this 232 rule
with that you know we don't want to
specify it using the rule the rule has
nothing to do with what the state is
other than defining the bit depth and
the dimension which we need to know does
it deal with three-dimensional cia's
currently no there's another program
that that is used for 3d name escapes me
okay okay okay then just assume okay if
it's a bit for now if it's a if it's a
sparse array with zeros and ones export
it with this default rule if it isn't
zeros and ones given our message okay
and the error message should say you
need to give a rule specification okay
meanwhile um okay yeah well that would
be lovely but that requires some kind of
fum
I mean did you guys look at that linking
to this code base I thought somebody had
actually implemented that at some point
yes no waiter then I think it's in Jose
stands at this point to do with anything
with so large I have not heard about
that okay okay all right you know what
I'm gonna do I'm going to so we've got a
plan for twelve point one here of how to
put basic support in there right make
sense
this is a 12-0 backward incompatible
with her switching from the default
image to default array but I think
that's a good change yes why are we I
didn't even know this was in twelve oh
it was but we never reviewed it we did
it's experimental okay then we switch
and it was kept experimental for the
same reason leave it as experimental but
we're switching okay okay um okay fine
listen guys this was a nicely presented
well done thing and you know it's a pity
that the sort of underlying strategy
wasn't quite right
the what I'm going to do there are two
people one who originally worked on
golly one who's a Suzy estimate in
current times I'm going to connect you
guys to them and I'm gonna let you guys
work out how to actually make this
connection work properly
and okay so but but we've got something
to put into 12:1 make sense let me
mention something one of the
complications were thoroughly rules is
the weird girls like Patterson's worms
termites the other 2d so 2d Turing
machines they've they've come up with a
whole bunch of different weird rule
systems hundreds of them and usually the
only thing they specify in the RLE is a
single pixel
okay so there's a there's a language of
those rules specifications presumably
right some author somewhere will come up
with a rule system like Patterson worm
and I'm sure you know what I just
realized you know what I realized I'm
sorry I realized how we do the rule that
this is some I realized how we should do
this I was wrong and what I wrote
originally said this isn't what we
should do we shouldn't have the initial
condition in there that's just wrong
what we should do is this whole thing
becomes the cellular automaton because
cellular automaton can represent
symbolically a cellular automaton do you
see what I'm saying
and then what we return is just that and
the initial condition did you see what
I'm saying because then what you can do
to run it is you just apply the cellular
automaton to that initial condition but
this becomes so in the case of a Turing
machine for example we have a symbolic
specification for those two so you
basically are translating the
representation of whatever it is into
that into our symbolic representation
that makes sense
and in worst case that translates into
an evolution function
I think that's unlikely to be you know
by the time it's some general piece of
lower code or something I think we have
a we were working with the lower people
on some kind of hook up to to lower um
and you know in the worst case it's a
weird piece of external code that's
running but um you know but it should
just work right in other words if that
first argument so just to clarify what
this does right the way it's set up if I
just say solar automaton 30 that becomes
you know that's just a thing it's it's
there right but if I were to apply that
to an initial condition or to a state
that are okay the although I default is
periodic boundary conditions which might
be different from those but that we'll
worry about that later
um I don't even know what is what is
their default boundary condition
[Music]
Xero's okay alright so in that case then
we would we would return something like
this and that oh that's interesting that
okay so that is in fact giving us the
correct thing that has that is correct
to be fed back into the soil automaton
that says keep their being zeroes on the
boundary so that's right it means that
the thing will change size but if we do
an S list on to this it will change size
which is a little weird and not what you
get if you do multiple steps at a time
but still correct right that's correct
it's just eating into the boundary okay
so that remains then that you know
looking at this hierarchical arrays is a
separate thing another thing which I
think would be interesting and maybe one
of the guys who's worked on on the whole
Gauley thing would like to help us with
this is is this kind of thing using
probably since that's mostly of interest
for two DCA's which we haven't optimized
we've optimized one DCA's really
extremely well um but I don't think
we've optimized 2d ones because we
haven't optimized them for the sparse
case I mean we've probably actually done
a pretty good job of optimizing dense
ones but not sparse ones so all right
well look I think this is this is the
main thing we wanted from this review
and you know as I say nicely presented
good work nice and clean um you know a
few strategic bumps we will connect you
to the right people and hopefully get
that dealt with okay if I could make
some suggestions yeah well if ending mcl
just to pull and
multicolored data should be a priority
well you know there's a limit to how
much we are going to do in this
particular area I mean let's just see um
the let's see what yeah I understand
that M cell is interesting yes
what's next and pick the rules we want
to support like 2d throwing machines
yeah well I understand so that for that
we need the grammar for which we need to
talk to the people who've worked on this
or look at the source code and also
decide which ones we don't want to
implement like better some firms any
rules can be implemented it's just a
question as I just explained right by
using the scheme of having a function
that does the evolution be the thing you
return yes no I'm saying any rule can be
implemented right which ones we choose
to implement and how that works I do not
know the boundary right but any rule can
be implemented there's no limit right so
it's just a question of understanding
what's there and what the right path is
to implement these things because
they're implemented you know inside
golly in some form right maybe we just
use that implementation by calling some
external language okay right so that we
don't have to re-implement it and get it
wrong and you know and copy the bugs and
all that kind of stuff it may be maybe
there's a way of having golly disgorge
that piece of code you know it's not
used to disgorge encoder but maybe they
could put something into it that will
let one export with the code and then we
can import the code and you know if it's
something like lore or Python we can
probably just run it this isn't yeah all
right that's I think a very small
practical discussion where do we want
this to be implemented I think the
mappings should be implemented or better
be implemented in cellular automaton not
an important
no no no what which mappings they're
part of import/export this is nothing to
do with cellular automata if they're if
it's a mapping from some weird rule
format to our cellular automaton
function it goes in the import-export
frameworks so we don't want things like
b3 s 23 as a string he's so poor that no
I mean we may have something called rule
string in this format that gives you the
string form but that isn't really very
interesting to us because there's not a
lot we can do with it so yeah perhaps
rule system and then you have the name
of the rule and then the particular
index no I don't think so we want it in
a form that is as I've said now five
times that is a function that can be
applied to the data too this would be a
function like rule system patterson worm
no no no because we don't know what that
means right
that needs to turn into something which
is a Turing machine where I think that
one is more mobile automaton the you
know that has turned into something that
says Turing machine off blah blah blah
blah right so that we can natively
implement it not implement we can
natively simply run it right so that the
onus is on the import-export framework
to take what exists in the aurélie file
and turn it into something that will
natively run in our system that makes
sense wouldn't it be good though to also
allow people to disk use a particular
rule system once we've got it like and
then they wouldn't have to go through
Gauley to get it okay that's a separate
issue that's basically an issue of
string names in things like Turing
machine just like we have string names
in cellular automaton and I think we
have a data repository collection of
rules don't we we were supposed to have
that do we have a collection of rules in
the data repository that just translate
named rules into specifications if we
don't have that we should have that
right that's the right place for that
or alternatively if we really
that much about it we should put it in
the entity system as an entity type
seller otamatone rule where we can have
names and linguistics and so on for them
that's probably the right thing to do
ultimately and something that I mean I
don't know did you produce an entity
store version of the information about
soever automata for the data repository
ad yes for life
yes okay I know but I'm asking for these
other rules and no so that were several
generations okay so that would be a
thing to do that will be the thing to do
is to make an entity store with those
named rules right translating from the
names from the entities into our
specification for cellular automaton
that would be a useful thing to do to
achieve this okay okay
all right let's wrap it up here I'm
shadi I can give you a few more minutes
on this video stuff just stay right here
and anybody who wants to stay can stay
otherwise people who are not relevant to
this can drop off and okay let me just
take your list of information here okay
so these functions video okay so these
are this is analogous to the video to
image apply and so on correct okay you
folks throw me mirrored oh no okay thank
you okay so I mean the one of these that
seems crazy to me is video filter maybe
I'm wrong that that's crazy or is that
is that what you mean by a video filter
this is the one that takes
tens of video and audio data and then
processes them in chunks would be useful
if you're tracking objects for instance
is it the same is it analogous to image
filter in a sense because you can
specify a chunk size a partition size so
okay so these functions basically are
the direct analogs are image apply image
map etc is that true
image map we don't have image video map
is generalization of map really so the
function f can return anything the
output is in a time series your video
block output is time series the input is
just a list of video frames or audio
samples but so what is the when you say
block map is that doing essentially a
moving average in the I mean is it
taking a block of video frames of time
or what yes it could be a moving average
if the function f is mean okay so the
issue here was me complaining that this
isn't look if we have okay so let's
understand this so image a video apply
applies after each frame of the video so
that's analogous to image apply which
applies to each pixel is that correct
correct so what it would look like is
video apply of image apply if I want it
to like recolor eyes you know but pixel
um I would say image video apply of
image apply of whatever that's a little
confusing you could do video apply of
color negate video no no but I'm saying
I could use image apply inside video
apply and that is revealing both the you
the the slight sort of corruption of
both these names because image apply is
really image pixel apply and video
applies early video frame apply correct
okay so the question is will we regret
this I mean image apply you know so what
we're doing here is video is taking
things in granularity of frames whereas
the image functions well some of them
are taking in a granularity of pixels
yes does that bother you I mean I think
it doesn't really bother me that much
because I don't think I don't think
there's going to be a notion you know
both images and video seem to have you
know this digital notion which I don't
think is going to go away in other words
you can't really imagine you know what
we are dealing with images that are made
of pixels and videos that are made of
frames and I don't think either of those
is going to change all right okay let me
look at video block map here and let me
look at video filter how do you specify
the duration presumably can be in frame
number or it can be a time in seconds
presumably yes um you know you should
say that it can be just an integer right
it's a number of frames video buffer a
specific duration so image filter works
range our neighborhood so that's
effectively like a solar automaton with
the R by R well is it no range R on each
side right it's consistent with the
cellular Thomasson so R equals 1 is a
single border
on each side correct yes to our plus 1
square yeah okay okay and this offset
mechanism okay so is there a similar
thing here no so there's no way up to
always move by your pic still and it's
it may make sense to do it the same for
video filter as well I I haven't come
across an application yet that I want to
move with a different offset and which
unless you saw in video filter in video
filter and none of them actually but for
video filter imagine you're following
objects tracking things really you
typically want to offset by one well you
might also want to down sample exactly I
was gonna say only if you want to do
things like down sampling which I assume
we're gonna have specific everything
function to do down Sam I would have
fire we want another argument to do the
offset because I think that what you're
doing here is the duration here I could
imagine that you would want a symmetric
duration and no no no no no I'm saying
think about the time stamps that you are
generating right okay let's say you say
this explosion happened at T equals five
seconds all right you don't want but
let's say that the analysis you're doing
is not symmetrical around the you know
the T mark so to speak for every T right
so I'm saying you need a way to specify
a duration that is like image filter a
symmetric right okay but you see that
image filter or row or column or we also
have our topper
that's the case yes because it because
that that would be analogous now I don't
know whether I mean I'm not sure if this
is a desirable thing because partition
for example doesn't work that way
partition is just an offset kind of
thing all right
do we have a function video partition
we're gonna have no not - oh boy
okay but I mean it's that difficult just
that yeah no I understand that but but
so but I mean to go from a video to a
list of images how do you do that okay
there are two ways either you have the
video is just out of course so you
always have a file path you can import a
specific video frame or else we are
introducing the video stream similar to
audio stream I don't think that's a good
idea
look what we need to be able to do like
for audio where this isn't relevant you
need to be able to get the instantaneous
frame at T equals 5 seconds from the
video easily something video tape or
some such yeah maybe but video take will
be with spans I think you want to get
something where literally by frame
number or by time maybe with a sub value
from video you can just extract the
image just a beginner video frame takes
just a beginner I wouldn't do that
because because that way you're taking
multiple well yeah but no but why not
just do it with sub values on the video
object itself is there a reason I mean
it's there an obvious reason why we
don't do that for image as well if you
want the pixel value at certain pixel
position image why not use a sub value
no I guess we could do that for for
image they internal presentation changed
address twice over the versions from
yeah I know but no their cell values
could work there is one practical issue
for video with submit well which is not
you know this
our values could still work but when you
ask for a specific frame you have to
decode all of the frames up to that
position if you say roughly time yeah
exactly
it takes time if you're cool with it if
you say roughly time what it's it's okay
they're seeking the approximate time
could happen if you say jump to the
minute five that could be done faster
but if you say jump to frame it fine
well okay that's an argument for what
why is that faster because there are
some some frames had already been
reconstructed or something that don't
require it's only okay but why don't you
just go to the frame that the most
recently reconstructed frame and start
reconstructing from there I I have to
look into that I'm not sure but I'm on
possible because if you can get frame
about five minutes you presumably know
which frame number that was and you know
you know you go to that approximate
frame number right and then you go I'll
have to check on that yes from there
what what what we have discussed it
poetry said we we cannot know when you
get a frame that is roughly around five
minutes you can't you cannot guarantee
this is exactly that frame number that
you asked for but I can understand that
but I'm saying if you know what frame
number it is then you can go from there
if it if if that gives you frame number
2000 or something then and you've asked
for a frame 2015 then you obviously just
go to the thing that's abusing you tip
whatever status but it's not a
gauranteed mm it's oh I know I listen to
what I'm saying so you say get me a
frame around 2015 okay it goes and
fetches frame 2003 okay yep and and then
so long as you know that it's frame 2003
you're easily able to go forward some
number of frames yeah right so the only
way that it would be bad which I can't
imagine is the case is if you don't know
which frame number the thing you
actually extract it is mm-hmm right yeah
okay so okay
so hold on a second so what we want um
in this model where you have things like
video apply video filter and so on I
mean what does image take do image take
takes a sub part of the image right
I'm wondering whether this should simply
be I mean video take of that comma n
could give you a list of the first end
frames in the video I think that's fair
yes and then image take see as you say
the thing that people mostly want is
give me a frame around the five-minute
mark or something or another typical
thing people are gonna want is give me a
sequence of frames you know give me sort
of a thumbnail of the image of the video
by getting a sequence of frames every
however many seconds or they're gonna
want two things they're gonna want that
and they're gonna want give me n frames
into you know space through the video
yep
does the thumbnail function work on
video it's it will said so well we can
discuss that you and I us have never
discussed any of this my proposal is
that any image or audio function that
makes sense to work on video on video
frames and video audio samples should
just work so image take should just crop
the frames the image frames in the video
into whatever specification you have
specified then something like video take
is gonna be taking or cropping video
over time thumbnail in under that scheme
is gonna return the whole thumbnail
version of the video so it's it's seem I
don't think that's right I think
thumbnail has got to return a single
image thumbnail because I think that
there are too many uses it's got to do
its best to pick out an interesting
frame and just return
thumbnail okay that's the only thing it
can do I think we should go through the
whole list of functions to see what
makes sense what doesn't make sense okay
so but the things that are going to be
important immediately are this business
about extracting frames look you're
gonna need something which says okay so
what do we need we need extract a
particular frame I don't know how
important that is I mean you know your
your extract your frame around this time
look what we want is something which
says video what will be the analog and
time series to get a thing at a
particular time it's just a sub value
isn't it it is a something yes right so
I think that's what this should be I
think if you want if you give here if
you give video and you give a sub value
that has units in it right and you will
get the the approximate you know that
frame that approximate frame right right
an integer that will try to give you
that exact frame now we can have another
function that is more sophisticated here
but I think what should happen okay so I
think there should be a thing called I'm
not sure that's the right term
but it takes a video and an N and gives
you n frames of the video you know gives
you images n images space through the
video right because that to me is not
necessarily equally well as equally as
we can get them okay
and the whole point there I mean the
best thing to do would be with the
metadata of each image with the meta
information of each image giving
timestamp information right because that
to me you know if I get a random video
that's a super useful operation for me
because I don't want to watch the video
I just want to see the thumbnails
basically and and then presumably if you
say thumbnail of that you would get the
thumbnails and maybe video sampling
could have an a second or a third
argument that just says thumbnail that
would give it's just sample thumbnails
from each of those images without having
to be asked because that might be
significantly more efficient what are
those things called there's there's a
name for for video turned into a bunch
of frames I think not sure what it is
but whatever it is I think we need this
function I mean that just turned it into
n frames where n I mean there's some
decoration about you want to frame at
the very beginning do you want to frame
at the very end you know where the end
frames go but fundamentally this is the
useful thing and you know for lots of
kinds of analysis and and this
particular thing if we do the syntax
correctly could turn into just give me
it frame by frame right so like for
example if we said video sampling a
video and that would be n frames I don't
know this is a good idea but but
something like that would be give me
every single frame maybe and this would
be you know give me I mean so there's
two cases give me n frames I think we've
had this in other functions give me n
frames spaced out evenly through the
video and give me specifically every
every frame I actually um
[Music]
isn't this function see that gives you
hmm not quite I mean you might also want
okay
okay so the only you want from video
sampling is give me something that is
yeah okay so what do we need here we
need we need fraction of the way through
the video we need n frames total we need
the nth frame and we need every and nth
frame I think those are the obvious
things I think to need and we might need
a list of frames which might be faster
to extract and one go than in multiple
pieces by making sense yeah my gosh I
don't have a very of subsection here you
make one go ahead for all of those we
probably want some size specification as
well what do you mean oh you mean the
size of the final frame right do you
want the original size thumbnail or just
a specific size okay so we need a syntax
that covers these things and we need an
analogue of this we probably had an
analogue of this and maybe we need
different functions for several of these
but these seem you know okay let me make
a comment this is one of these icing on
the cake type things that we absolutely
need yep right fairly easy to do but we
absolutely need it so
[Music]
I mean we could call it I don't know
what the the n frames total the nth
frame oh yeah we not frame okay that
then we also want at some point frame
around timestamp T all about a thing
like if it's called something like video
images that extract video frames well
possibly uh okay so then the question is
[Music]
that could be the total how do we get
the nth frame and how do we get every
nth frame and we may need a different
[Music]
see we got total n versus every nth
frame seems like the best specification
in histogram and so forth yeah how does
that work that has typically have double
lists and things like that it's fairly
confusing I don't know if you have
rappers to use for that well what we
have for histogram is is comma one means
one bin brace one means a bin of width
one right right and the double list is
just yeah like specification right so in
that an analogue this would be n things
across and that would be that would mean
every end frames and video frames
without an end there would probably just
give you every single frame a list of
every single frame I'd be crazy well it
might be crazy but if it's a short video
it's not crazy okay I mean if it's an
incredibly long video maybe we default
to something okay how about a frame
every second yeah say much safer
currently we have the same problem in
import of a video comma image list which
is asking exactly for all frames okay
but so this here if we give a time here
that could mean every that not well yeah
I think that means every time every you
know every frame spaced by time it
should be consistent with that end case
video comma and if comma n means true
the end frame 0 to n time means no no no
no no no no that doesn't that's not what
that means that means n frames total
through the video I see and this would
be time and the other case would be a
frequency right which is directly
analogous I think to the well I mean but
once we have units you know if we say at
point 1 the
yeah I mean I actually think the
frequency is gonna solve them all of
that we can just say one frame per
second or one frame per minute or
whatever sure but if you give one minute
I think you might as well just assume
that's an inverse and take it by
frequency right the time you could give
the time and assume that that's the
frequency that means one per that amount
of time I see okay all right I'm
probably confusing this with video take
which would return a video of a given
time just every single consecutive frame
right no this is this you really want
this space over time yes yes right which
is why it's called video frames I like
this I think this is pretty good I may
suggest we make it a bit more specific
like video sample frames cuz video
frames may be confusing that you really
want a span of frames in fact we could
would also support span here yeah we
could support span that's n frames total
butBut indexing into a video I strongly
think should be done by video blah blah
blah and then just the okay the only
question with that is if there's a span
I mean that should be the video frames
as a list I mean this would be this
would be an image here now what about
audio sampling I mean in other words if
you want audio but do you want that how
would you get audio sampled every you
know and that relates again to your
video map right because what you want
let's say I want a sample I want it to
be you know I want to hear two seconds
of video of audio every minute in the
video
right eg two seconds of audio every
minute in the video see what I'm saying
you know what we need a separate review
about this stuff why don't you have a
think about this stuff in the next few
days let's try and review this these
functions are all easy to build but
let's not make an icing mistake and do
you want all the icing for 12-1 yes
because we're not going to be able to
announce video it's one of these things
where we announce fantastical you know
computational geometry we forget to put
in triangles this is stuff we need this
is much more elementary than what you
already have but we need something here
okay I mean you know this is the this is
the simple stuff right stuff we have
hopefully we have all the big stuff sirs
by understand I understand you've got
the difficult things typical mistake
right you've done the difficult stuff
but now there's some easy stuff we've
got to do the easy stuff because if we
release it without the easy stuff people
will just be confused okay okay so why
don't you have a think about this won't
you get a meeting set up with me in this
few days a couple of days and let's see
if we can iterate this this this
shouldn't be too hard I mean this looks
I mean that you know let me just send
this to you um okay
very good thanks for much so um so
actually we have a bunch of comments
here on our livestream are you still
here shadi yep yeah if you're dressed
framed by sub value then also allow
range yes we agree with that you're
going to be able to create a thumbnail
list a video which will be every n
frames yep we won't pay attention here
but yes agreed video sub sample or over
load down sample oh that's a decent idea
um okay Brian from our live stream says
it'd be useful to be able to find all
the keyframes and return them or their
indexes because they won't need to be
reconstructed yes I agree
yeah I mean so so then in a sense that
would be you know video blah blah blah I
mean one could say just keyframes I
don't know that's a good idea
um right I mean oh yeah that's a good
point so so Santa is pointing out if you
do time as as the video frames thing
then um the then it might not be you
know it might offset it might not align
with the the frame rate but that's life
I mean the number of frames if you ask
for time you're gonna get something that
it's roughly that amount of time if you
want frames then ask for now a number of
frames audio wouldn't you want to find
the start of the audio for a particular
frame yes you probably would you
probably want what you probably want
okay so you might want a G a collection
of frames together with you know a
second of audio or something starting at
that frame or possibly not starting at
that frame so how would you return that
you would have an image and an audio
that would be a pair image an audio
what's that that's one representation
yep okay so I agree that there's a okay
hold on I mean there's a video okay look
you've said video take right so video
take of a video returns a video
basically and that video take could be
could have a frame number
and that obviously it would work just
like take so a frame number would be n
frames from the beginning or it could be
a time presumably yep now and that would
allow you now there's a question here
about down sampling of whether I think
it's obscure to call it video downsample
and have it returned
you know n little thumbnails I think
well video down sample is a different
issue of just getting a video that has
been down sampled and presumably that's
doable with video take by just giving a
video take with you know I mean you
could if you really wanted to you do
this um to get a downsampled video it's
a little bit good well that's not that
bad um but so that is video to video and
I don't know what happens to the audio
when you down sample what happens to the
audio when you down sample we do have
audio sample with me down sample every
hundred frames it's like what are you
gonna do with the audio oh yeah it's not
gonna sound good I guess but I'm not
sure that that's what wants to do I mean
that one might want to treat the audio
different way in that case like you
might want to down sample the video I
don't really see how you do this what
way if it's video to video there's
really nothing you can do other than
just sample a piece of audio I think
yeah but the case where you want to get
frames out I mean that's where we're
dealing with video frames um
and I mean I'm trying to think what you
want okay so look the obvious thing to
do if you want frames you know is not
try and put the start and end point
inside the frames but just do a video
take and then say video frames over the
video take if you want to get a
particular start and end point
um yeah
all right well have a think about this I
I'm why are you unhappy about the name
video frames here it seems like it's
that's exactly what it's giving you is
that no I'm not anymore I was I was
thinking if you're looking into take
taking full span of frames with video
frames then that's not easily allowing
us to do that but with the sub value
that you're both what you would do is
you would say video frames okay so this
in fact would I I recant here
I'd say get every frame or maybe there's
a or maybe a heuristic yeah if it's just
absurd to get a reframe maybe I mean
what we could do yeah we could do we
could define it as being the min of you
know either a one-second one frame I'm
not sure
okay so here's what we could do we could
have a max items option here in video
frames and if you hit max items
something like that it could it could
start down sampling but in the case
where if you want you know video take
video and then you would say time 1 time
2 or frame number but those are
distinguishable by units yep right then
that's how you would get all frames from
time one to time two and if you really
wanted DT you would get du DT tit here
and yes you might you might not align
okay so what you would have to do here
is that DT could be not a time unit but
like a 3 for example that means step by
frames yep within that time interval yep
thanks
now I also think you need to make sure
that at some point that we support data
interval
I suspect there's a time interval coming
as well but I mean that's a that's just
a um a detail for that this will be very
nice this should be very easy let's
let's um I would like to see this and I
particularly video frames for you know
comma N for total of n frames to
summarize a video
seems highly used are we down to these
two functions and videotape oh no video
take video frames and I think the one
thing that okay so probably what we want
here is the special case of video frames
yeah I'm taking this back here this
isn't right well I don't know that that
we could have that there but if we say
video frames video oh actually this is
another possible meaning well keyframes
then that would give the I don't even
know how our keyframes defined are they
defined by the image by the body
compression algorithm I don't know I
think I think so I think it's gonna be
different for each and Kody okay and
presumably we can query somehow the
number of keyframes that exists in the
video if again depends probably on the
encoding but I'll look into it look into
okay okay great
alright so I think that that string
setting keyframes is gonna open up
possibility of a lot of other string
settings as well that might be useful I
agree and I could even imagine that
thing arrow something to be more
specific and so on alright this is
actually this video stuff is always have
much more important than the RLE stuff
which I consider to be kind of a detail
I'm nice to have but a detail um so you
know if there's a choice in priorities
you know what to do
yes okay sounds great thank you thanks
to the folks on the livestream as well
see you later